[Music]
we've got major news dissidents three
heads wrapped filming in Vancouver stay
tuned to find out what we know and how
we got to hear the saddest news ever
we've got a year until descendants three
premiers
so subscribe to the things to stay
up-to-date and now here is everything we
know so far about Disney's descendants
three all the fields this is the third
descendants movie so it's been a pretty
major part of dub Cameron's and the rest
of the cast's lives the Emmy
award-winning star of the franchise has
been all up in her feels about the end
of filming it must be hard to end such a
huge and fun chapter of her life her
Twitter and Instagram have been totally
emotional we're not crying on June 28
2018 dub tweeted the sweetest post this
cast is the pride and joy of my life my
whole heart is in these people I grow
and I'm better every day because of
these people she rose she went on to say
that there are words that will always
fall short for how she feels about her
cast mates Sophia Carson retweeted
because she totally feels the same and
then dove tweeted a special shout-out to
the core for Sophia Carson booboo
Stewart and Cameron voice too sweet the
core for must feel like siblings at this
point we hope dub doesn't stay sad for
too long we expect great things from her
in the future but if we're sad the
franchise is almost over we can't
imagine all the feels the cast and crew
must have that's a wrap seriously what
would we do without social media thanks
to the descendants stars amazing social
media accounts we feel like we are right
there with them after doves emotional
tweet our news feeds were full of posts
about the ending of filming Sophia
Carson posted a really sweet video on
her Instagram on July 16 2018 it was a
beautiful sunset drive with some of the
cast it was one of the last times they
were ever going to leave the set she
described it's as perfect in every way
we wish we had been there Sophia Stubb
posted a selfie with Sophia and said
that the set was so emotional Dov also
posted the greatest picture a photo
frame shows the core for holding hands
her diary was just below
and said that it was the last day of
filming that's right July 16th 2018 was
when all the filming wrapped that gives
Disney a full year to tease us with
what's to come we hope a new trailer or
some more details drop soon we bet
vancouver is sad too to see the cast
leave but there's a ton of work left for
the crew to do connect summer just hurry
up already new villains they wouldn't be
a descendants movie without a bunch of
new villains although we know the names
and actors of the new villains disney
has kept a lot of the details under
wraps here's what we know
first up dr. Vasily R from The Princess
and the Frog is making an appearance he
is going to be played by Jamal Sims we
are curious if he's going to be a major
part of the movie or just a small
character dr. facile beer has a daughter
named Celia played by Jada since we
don't know if she's bad or has a
redemption story like our favourite V
Ches either way we are excited for some
awesome voodoo Cajun vibes Captain
Hook's right-hand man Smee has two twin
sons that will be in this movie it's
hard to imagine that two little kids
could be villains but we bet they get
into some hilarious trouble finally we
know that Hades god of the underworld
from Hercules will be making an
appearance he'll be played by Cheyenne
Jackson but we'll talk more about that
later we are so excited about all the
new characters and how they will fit
into the storyline we hope we see some
of the original villains two new sets
it's amazing how hush-hush Disney
Channel has kept everything to do with
the descendants three film but on July 6
2018 they posted one of the best updates
yet the official Disney descendants
Instagram account posts amazing hashtags
d3 deets videos this one showed us some
sneak peeks of the sets from descendants
three and just like the video said the
aisle and auradon have never looked
better
first we get an updated look at the Isle
and the castle then we see an awesome
fairytale house in the woods who does it
belong to the most exciting part in this
sneak peak comes next a sign with a
three-headed dog says beware of dog you
might remember that Cerberus is Hades
three-headed dog who guards the
underworld
between that sign and the underground
tunnel it looks like we will for sure be
seeing the underworld in the new movie
then we get an ocean shot and we know
the pirate kids are returning so that's
is likely for them we see a lovely
bridge over a creek and another shot of
the castle Disney is such a tease we
hope there are more set photos soon new
looks one of the things we love most
about The Descendants movies is the
costumes and we love all the seek peeks
we are getting at the updated looks
Disney released a photo of the core for
BK's new looks back on June 1st 2018 it
looked like they are ready for serious
business we're digging the colorful
leather looks on all four of them V's
red and black contrasts amazingly with
her blue hair we love mouths green and
purple boots with her purple ensemble
and both Carlos and J looks so cool the
pirate BK's got updates to which disney
revealed on June 15 2018 Pumas dreads
have been replaced with a perfect new
hairstyle and she's wearing patchwork
leather pants which seems way more
practical for a pirate Gill looks much
tougher in his new all brown leather
outfit and Harry has shed the bulky red
overcoat for a black vest and what might
be a first shirt they look so awesome
and so cool another character has a
totally new look which may stick though
an even bigger change we'll talk about
her next we can't wait to see all the
other characters new costumes good girl
gone bad
do you remember Audrey from the first
descendants movie she is the daughter of
Princess Aurora and Prince Philip and
she is the most popular girl at auradon
prep she gets dumped by Ben who falls in
love with Mao in the first movie she's
an antagonist but in the animated series
descend into wicked world she is friends
with mal and Evie although she's jealous
a lot of fans were upset when she was
intended in stew but the actress had
scheduling conflicts
she was mentioned as being on vacation
with her three fairy godmothers well
Audrey is back in descendants three and
she's got a whole new look in fact she
looks like a villain a photo was leaked
of her wearing her crown and an edgy
ensemble she also has hot pink hair the
most striking features that she is
holding Melissa
scepter and has an evil laugh frozen on
her face she is in the woods with Chad
we know that the woods seemed important
with the teaser trailer where mal sees
the blue light and says dad so what is
Audrey doing there has she really gone
evil or is she cursed how does she fit
as a villain when we also have dr. FATA
we're in Hades we have so many questions
think that's a huge bombshell keep
watching to find out what's next for our
stars who's our daddy
although Disney has not officially
confirmed it everyone is pretty sure
that Hades is mouths dad in the teaser
trailer we see mal walking through the
woods towards a blue light she says
surprised dad well we know Hades has a
blue flame on top of his head in the
original Hercules movie and we know
Hades will be in the new movie we've
seen a couple of sneak peeks of the
underworld where he lives - Hades sure
seems like the type of guy who could
make even Maleficent smooth and
vulnerable but not everyone is convinced
that this is the case one fan theory
suggests that Smee is the father the
book Isle of the Lost
describes Maus unknown father as we
can't even if we go by the book it would
need to be a human we aren't sure how
sound this theory is but it sure would
be interesting
another theory comes from the Pixar
universe the giant evil bear from brave
mordioux was a human originally he
learns the error of his ways and is
turned into a will of the wisp some
people have pointed out that the blue
light in the forest looks a lot like a
wisp we can't wait to find out for sure
who her dad is The Big Sleep
Disney has confirmed that the title of
the third film is The Big Sleep but we
have no idea what it means the first
movie was Isle of the Lost
which is a pretty obvious title as
that's where the villains were banned so
what could the Big Sleep mean one
possibility is that it has to do with
Maleficent Saturno sleeping spell the
star is Maleficent's daughter after all
it also looks like Sleeping Beauty's
daughter the last victim of the Sleeping
Beauty spell has turned evil maybe it
has something to do with Audrey she is
seen holding Maleficent sceptre The Big
Sleep could also relate to Hades
you foam isn't for what happened at the
end of a person's life and Hades is a
keeper of the underworld or maybe to get
to the underworld Mao must have a big
sleep and pretend her soul is filling
there the more do as Mao's father theory
also has something to do with Big Sleep
mordioux translates to big killer as a
killer sure is something that could
cause a big sleep we have no idea what
to expect by giving us the title Disney
just gave us even more questions
connecting to the plot
Disney still has not given us a
full-length trailer or a synopsis of
descendants three so we still have a lot
of questions about the plot so far we
know that we have two new villains Hades
and dr. facile ear it also looks like
there's a good chance Audrey is a new
villain are these three antagonists to
each other or do they team up we also
know that we will meet Smith Sons and
that Ouma and a crew are returning it's
a safe bet that some important stuff
happens at sea we also know that mouths
dad is an important part of the plot we
don't know whether she will discover his
identity at the beginning or the end of
the movie we don't know if finding him
is a part of the plot or if they'll
spends the movie forming a
father/daughter bonds we also expect to
find out what happened to Audrey did
something happen to her on a vacation or
did time and lapse between movies and we
assume we will find out what happened
after Malin umas major fight at the end
of a sentence - there's a lot of loose
ends to tie up
but we know Disney will do it for us
what's next we are so sad that The
Descendants franchise is ending in 2019
but the cast is so talented we know that
we won't be seeing the last of them dove
Cameron tweeted out their plans on June
26 2018 she said that she can't focus on
her music during filming but that music
will be her top priority she assured her
fans that she is in constant
communication with her label and feels
really good about where it's going we
cannot wait to hear new music from her
she's not the only one focusing on her
music booboo Stewart has been teasing
his Instagram followers about his
two-man band honey
Sophia Carson will be working on a new
movie called Asbury Park and starring as
Ava on Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionists we don't know in camera
voice will be up too but we're sure it's
something awesome like the other members
of the Corps for bouquets are you as
excited about descendents 3 as we are
what do you think is the most exciting
thing about the new movie let us know in
the comments and give this video a big
thumbs up and that's all for what we
know about descendents 3 The Big Sleep
don't forget to subscribe to keep up
with the new movie see you next time
[Music]